Let's make some improvements to our scatter plot. This
time we're going to start by switching from the qplot
syntax to the more formal and verbose ggplot syntax.
I mention this in Lesson 3. The ggplot syntax will
let us specify more complicated plots. So just as
a reminder, this is the qplot syntax in order
to create the scatter plot. Ggplot is another plotting
function similar to qplot, and it has slightly different syntax.
Here's the equivalent code to produce this scatter plot. The main
difference between qplot and ggplot is that we have to say
what type of geom or chart type that we want. In
this case, we want a scatter plot. So we're going to use the
geom_point. You can see the full list of chart types in
the ggplot reference, which is linked in the instructor notes. The second
big difference between the two plotting functions is that ggplot uses
this aes wrapper. We have to wrap our x and y variables
inside this aesthetic wrapper. Don't worry about this too much.
We'll cover this in more depth later. Now, I want to
get some ranges on my age, so I'm going to run
the summary command on age to figure out the lower and
upper limits. The minimum age of a user is 13,
and the maximum is 113. Now, let's click the x-axis
at age 90 and at age 13. This seems reasonable
since users who are younger than 13 are not permitted to
use Facebook. And we're really not that confident whether people who
report being older than age 90 are telling the truth. To
do this, we're going to use the xlim layer. Now I'm
not going to pass xlim into ggplot. Instead, I'm going to use it
as an additional layer outside of it. Notice that we use
the plus operator to add a new layer to our figure.
And this is going to change the appearance of our x-axis. I
really recommend that you add one layer at a time when building
up plots. This allows you to debug and find any broken code. And there we
go. There's a nicer plot with our users ranging from 13 to 90 years old.